all right everyone hello hello and
welcome back to the end game class as
always my name is caleb denby
and tonight uh on my final edition of
the end game class
actually i am going to be taking you
through some of what i believe to be
the greatest endgames ever played uh
looking at some chess history tonight as
well
uh with these greatest famous games so
you heard me correctly though this is my
final
endgame class for the near future dorsa
derek shawnee international master
better chest than i am
she will be taking over on the wednesday
classes
beginning next week so if you want to
see more of me check me out on tuesday
nights going forward with the road 2000
at 6 30 pm
central time uh without further ado
though let's get it underway here
i have some fun games to look at
starting with
this one between uh jose raoul
capablanca
and uh savely or tartakower
i don't know how to say his name to be
honest with you i should stop trying
uh anyways let's get into it here
so the position i have on the board for
you guys
is one that is perhaps not yet an
end game but we'll get there before too
long and i wanted to start with this
position
to highlight how the middle game
structures can shape
some end game plans so we have sort of
an unusual structure here not not too
crazy it's pretty clear that this came
from some kind of
nimzo indian with a capture on c3 or or
queen's indian for that matter
um and white ended up with these
random doubled c pawns right in addition
to that we have white with pawns on d4
and f4 and this backwards pawn on e3
also importantly a lot of the minor
pieces have already been traded
off the board so what does this mean for
uh for our end games coming up well
it means that's uh number one the end
game is sort of coming up here
once a file starts to open you're gonna
see the major pieces start to fall off
the board
and we'll get closer and closer to that
designation of an end game
so what should we be thinking about
doing as white here do we like
end games can we improve our chances in
any incoming endgames
with any changes in the structure so
let's think about it
how can we change the structure to try
and help our chances number one
in the current position of course in
number two in any
incoming endgames what what can be done
there
what should our plan be from here
and yeah hello everyone as you're all
filtering in uh
so yeah sorry for the slightly late
start here tonight we had to do a big
switch over um
from uh from the road 2000. but here we
are
okay nobody knows nobody knows what to
do
so here are some things that that
occurred to me
right number one we have these awkward
double pawns right we would love if we
could
somehow get rid of our awkward double
pawns but for the moment that doesn't
look very feasible right if we play
something like c5
i think black is going to be pretty
happy to play d takes and it's not like
we're really improving our structure
we're sort of just losing a pawn in the
meantime
though black also has sort of a weakness
in the position
in the form of this e6 pawn so a
favorable change in structure for white
is actually going to be if we can play
the move e4
and give ourselves access down this
e-file to one of black's weaknesses
in the process we're actually also
getting rid of a backwards pawn of
our own and we are opening up some
avenues for our bishop so definitely
e4 should be the the break should be the
change in structure on everybody's mind
here
uh and kappa blanca had this idea as
well and plays the move rook to e1 for
this reason
now i do want to speed up a bit as
we are mainly focusing on the end game
here rather than this slightly
late middle game position and so after
queen d7
by uh tartakower uh removing the queen
from the same file as the rook
we do see capablanca continue continuing
with this idea
of pawn to e4 the game continues with f
takes e4
and now a really nice move by cappa
blanca is queen takes c4
now this is a nice move not because it
threatens checkmate
but because it kind of forces a weakness
in the structure again
by tartakower uh generally these two
pawns
would like to stay put on h7 and g7
st kind of stay where they're at for the
moment later on in the end game it might
make sense to push them forward
but for now they're sort of safest uh on
their starting squares
so by forcing this pawn to g6 in this
position
we see that capablanca is is already
forcing some concessions
by by tardical right with the pawn on g6
you know black's opportunities on the
king side are perhaps a little bit more
limited
than they would be with the pawn still
back on g7
and later on these dark squared holes in
the position
may actually become relevant
uh so to continue now let's fast forward
a little bit more we have g3
by kappa blanca just showing up the
structure king f8 by tartakower making
sure there's no
nasty pins on the e file king g2
rook f7 just improving the king and
improving the rook a bit
because it's a little bit stuck on the
f6 square
and then we have h4 by uh by cappablanca
and so this is another great move
uh kind of in preparation for the end
game yes you can argue it's still about
the middle game at this point with so
many major pieces on the board
but gaining space on the king's side is
definitely going to be advantageous for
cabba blanca
in both the middle game and the end game
so notably you know these players
still playing this late middle game
position but definitely
keeping the end game in mind
particularly capablanca
opening up this e-file to access
weakness and
apply some pressure to force more
weaknesses in the structure
these are definitely end-game minded
ideas
now we have d5 by tardichower so this is
tardikower's response to having to deal
with this weakness on e6
by playing d5 in a sense he's activating
this knight on a5
and he's daring white to take on d5 and
remove this weakness off the board
however kappa block is not necessarily
unhappy about this
because this pawn on c4 wasn't doing so
great either so we actually do see cd5
ed5 and now we do see all the pieces
fall off the board
and we get the start of what what is
essentially just an
end game at this point so how should we
continue with cappa blanca uh what are
our
goals in this end game how can we try to
press for a win because white definitely
should
be the one pressing in this situation
so yeah you guys came up with some good
plans for the end game
i might have not been super clear what i
wanted you guys to find
was improving plans for cappa blanca
that had the end game in mind
so when capoblanco was was playing these
plans wasn't necessarily
you know an endgame plan but it was a
plan to improve his endgame
right he improves his endgame by
targeting black's weakness he improves
the end game
by uh forcing these pawns to make some
some concessions
so yeah az or arizona i don't know
lionheart312
has exactly the right idea here we don't
necessarily need to play
g4 in this case as uh as chess king is
saying
you know this isn't a bad idea either
just improving the king continuing with
g4
and then playing h5 but there's there's
simply no need for it here
uh h5 immediately is a great great move
and the reason this move is so powerful
uh is because end games are all about
peace activity
and in general uh in end games with more
than one piece on the board like this
where we have a knight a rook and a
bishop and a rook
the rook activity is the one that's
going to matter the most and this is
sort of a
rule that that tends to hold true in
most end games the most valuable piece
on the board
is the most important piece to activate
uh and in this case
the rook is definitely the most valuable
piece on the board the most powerful
piece on the board and the most
important one to
activate so while h5 on the surface
seems to be activating the bishop it's
actually more about giving this rook an
avenue
to to get into the game you can compare
this with a move
a weaker player might make like rookie
one check like rookie one check seems
like a perfectly fine move right
and it is a perfectly fine move but the
problem is after rookie 7
you don't have much better than trading
rooks right you can play rook e5
but black is likely going to probably
not take it
um but but play something like knight c6
actually maybe not knight c6 but
knight c4 took me a while to get there
but knight c4 and this tactic
is is saving black's position i think so
uh knight c4 and then you really don't
have anything better than to trade
and i do believe that this end game is
uh a draw unless i'm horribly mistaken
so a weaker player might think open file
on the board
i should occupy this with my rook and
put it on the powerful e5 square
but it's all about rook activity and the
way to get active with the white rook
is along the h file also really
importantly
the open e file is not really all that
useful to black
all of these squares are already covered
and after a move like king f3 or king f2
the e3 square is also unavailable to
black so h5
fantastic move that activates white's
rook and
at the same time keeps black from from
entering the game
uh in response to this black already has
a tough decision
black definitely doesn't want to take on
h5 because this
really does allow the rook immediately
into the game as well as giving white a
uh protected past pawn so instead rook
f6
is a better try by tartakower but at
this point the idea is going to be
exactly the same now for capablanca
simply takes on g6 takes on g6
and rook h1 again the e file
not so valuable we can't really make
effective use of it
but the h file there are plenty of entry
points here
for the white rook to invade on
uh and so capablanca is just much better
in this endgame already
we see king f8 by tardekhower trying to
bring the king over to defend the
weakness on g6 and stop any
uh nasty uh okay we'll stop nasty check
and rook h7 ideas i suppose
or rook h7 or g7 ideas that is
but of course rook h7 is is still a
playable move and a quite good move
uh now you might have noticed a problem
for white
and that is that rook c6 number one
defends the pawn on f6
and number two attacks the pawn on c3
so what should be white's response to
this how should white respond
and apparently the video is lagging
a bit hopefully it's getting a bit
better
uh if you do experience the the lag live
i
think uh it is just a
a problem with live streaming so the
recorded version should be smooth
if you you do need to you know leave
and come back to watch the video later
i'll be sad but it should be better
if it's unwatchable
ah and now i actually see the lag too
that's so sad
that's so sad maybe i can convince my
boss
to buy a better laptop for the studio
okay anyways let us uh continue on here
so how should white respond to this
it turns out that the threat to the pawn
on c3
is actually not so not not so great you
know it's not so critical
that our c3 pawn lifts and that's due to
the proactive steps capablanca took
before getting into this
end game right cappablanca immediately
way back here
recognized this potential three versus
two majority on the king's side
and started gaining space on this side
of the board as quickly as possible
with h4 and that really comes in handy
once we arrive at this position because
now even if black could get
active play by taking on c3 even if
all four of these pawns disappeared from
the board it doesn't really matter
if white wins g6 and promotes the king's
side pawns first
right what good is it having four pawns
against two queens you know what i mean
so of course white should continue
furthering uh these pawns on the king's
side
without really worrying too much about
the queenside pawns
white is a head in this pawn race and so
white should can
should white in that lead rather than
take steps to try to defend over here
for example
something like king f2 trying to come
defend
is simply unnecessary right you don't
need the king over here
to defend against this kind of stuff
anyways um
yes so g4 is the right idea in the end
game
no need to take note of black's play
over here
when we can just advance our pawns on
the king's side knight c4
played in the game and again no uh
no cause for alarm for kappa blanca just
yet of course rook takes c3 is suicidal
after bishop takes g6 as stated f5 f6 is
coming and then
actually just checkmate uh so knight c4
instead we see
g5 now by uh cappa blanca
uh which again is just following the
same rule right just advancing these
pawns advancing the majority
trying to create a pass pawn and win the
game knight e3 check played
by tartakower we see king f3 and now
knight f5
and the the simple move is sometimes
correct here in the form of bishop takes
f5
right this knight's in the way right now
with this knight
guarding against our threat to the g
pawn it simply must be removed
so we see takes and takes and then
probably the
the move of the game here by by cappa
blanca
so white to move and find
the move of the game what do you guys
think in the chat room
try to give this one a thought and wow
chess king didn't need to give it a
thought
just already has the right idea
already has the right idea
um and yeah so principles can sort of
guide you on this one
as well so just as back earlier when
kappa blanco played h5
the key principle to follow was
activating your most powerful piece
in this game in this position rather
that principle still holds true the rook
on h7 is already very active
but we need now to activate the king as
well and another principle to follow for
this
is essentially the fewer pieces on the
board the more important the role of the
king is
so when there's a knight and a bishop
still left on the board
the king is going to have some problems
navigating his way
up to help in many many cases but with
these pieces off the board
there's nothing stopping this king from
coming all the way into black's camp
and helping out in the fight now what's
the way to do that well
these squares are all unavailable to us
so of course
king g3 is the key move in this position
again
not even remotely caring about the pawn
on c3
we want to come promote on the king's
side so rook takes c3 played in the game
of course now we should continue with
king h4 nothing else to do
rook f3 and now uh the the
accurate follow-up by cappa blanca is
the move g6
rather than king h5 of course it's all
about speed in this case
and the fastest way to get the king in
to help promote the pawn is by playing
g6 first
and if there really is one rule to take
away from this end game
it's the extreme value of activity and
you're pushing your past pawns right
kappa blanca
could not care less about any of these
pawns it's all about making the g pawn
into the queen to win the game we see
rook takes
f4 with check in the game king g5
and now rook e4 and why not rook takes
d4
well simply because you lose immediately
this is a checkmate threat
and if you try to run away i'll simply
make a big queen
and while you do have a lot of pawns
they're not going very far
and uh not helping you out very much
um and okay something is happening
all right i'm receiving a skype call
didn't know skype was
installed on this computer all right it
went away
no harm no foul i guess okay
so can't do that because you would
promote into a queen
uh everybody agrees so and also sorry if
you go this other way
i pull a switcheroo i pull a switcheroo
and checkmate you from the left
so rookie 4 is a forcing move now king
f6 and king g8 is the the idea
the difference now is that when we pull
the big switcheroo
there is a rook ready to stop the
checkmate
so wait to move here i think a lot of
people would play rook takes c7 without
thinking but of course
cappa blanca is just so so accurate all
the time
everybody hates it he throws in rick g7
check now
why do you throw in rook g7 check
because king f8 is unplayable
for the first point um well actually
maybe king of fate isn't unplayable
but you would get checked again perhaps
wait a second what's wrong with king f8
what's wrong with king f8
um perhaps yeah the king is is fine on
f8 actually
i think it's the same problem regardless
of where you go
uh but yeah essentially it's important
to drive the king further away
uh to a square where it can be checked
by the pawn so that's the problem with
king f8 by pushing it off of the g8
square
now g7 is always going to come with with
check and that is the the accuracy there
so rook takes c7 now rookie 8 is still
forced to stop the checkmate
and just king takes f5 like why not grab
this pawn
now that you can um and so
by solely prioritizing this peace
activity and advancing this pawn
what capoblanca has done at the cost of
the c3 pawn and the f4 pawn
is pretty much immobilized uh blacks
black's pieces black now has to focus
solely on stopping this pawn
and with that being black soul focus uh
now blacks
pawns are the ones that start to fall
rookie four
played in the game but this is a sort of
useless threat against king f6
when checkmate is again threatened now
we see rook f4 check
king e5 rook g4 and then again
the piece activity tells the tale here
with the king on h8 so far away we can
simply play g7 check
and this pawn is uncapturable due to the
distance
of this king we simply are promoting
with ease against uh the black king so
far away
so g7 check effectively defends the pawn
king g8 played
and then we just start cleaning up rook
takes a 7 played
rook g1 king takes d5 and the rest is
sort of history with two pawns up
white just advances this pawn kicks the
rook off of that
off of that file pushes and
tartakower resigns here um and
i've included this game in my list of
greatest end games of all time
because it it looks so effortless by
cappa blanca
but the decisions he was making in that
late middle game
really led him to this end game where he
was able to
to sort of show such such finesse right
he focused solely on the activity
and it worked for him because he had
made those gains
in the late middle game so questions on
this end game before we move on
to look at something else
questions on this end game
as it gets kind of chilly in the studio
okay well let us move along then uh
up next i actually in the road 2000
um didn't have time to analyze one game
that i wanted to go over between one
karpov and kasparov
now of course they played many many many
many many many
many games and so i have another one i
would like to show you
from the perspective of end games and
this is perhaps
uh one of well okay of course it's one
of the greatest end games karpov i've
ever played because i think it's one of
the
greatest end games ever played so nobody
cares about the openings
nobody nobody cares by the way this one
i believe is from the 1984
uh slash 1985 world championship don't
ask me to remember the game number
i just i will never i will never
um okay um again what are we doing this
is an endgame class
none of this looks like an end game it's
too complicated
too many pieces i'm just so upset by the
number of pieces on the board
get all these pieces out of here okay
rook d4
we're approaching the semblance of an
endgame here
and uh yeah we we can sort of start from
here
but the real end game is going to start
in just a few moments
so we have this position on the board uh
where
we have all of these pawns on light
squares and we have two light-squared
bishops on the board
and that's basically the only imbalance
worth noting right we have this bad
bishop versus good bishop
and for that reason karpov is going to
be a bit better going to have a few more
targets to look at in this endgame
but nothing crazy so far now in the game
we see king e7
and already karpov gets to work
targeting these pawns
we see knight a2 bishop back to c8
knight b4
king d6 so just eyeing up both
weaknesses
and also coordinating with this bishop
against these pawns
now a pretty interesting move by karpov
is the move f3
with the point being you play against
the knight by taking away
its outposts this sometimes rings true
in the end game as well
the knight steps back to g8 in search of
brighter pastures
we see h4 now knight h6
king f2 and the knight jumps out to f5
which is also a very reasonable square
all right so knight c2 by karpov and f6
by kasparov and now i want to get
into the big decisions alright we've got
some big decisions to make now
how should we continue with white
it feels as if we should be better
because our opponent has such a bad
bishop
but for the moment all of the targets
are pretty effectively defended
and in the meantime this night is pretty
annoying so what's step one here what is
step one for us
what is step one here
an exquisite corpse thinks he knows the
[Music]
game
and i'll give you guys a hint um well
not in this position but in the end game
as a whole
we're going to see a lot of the same
themes that we saw against capablanca
and tartakower uh there's some things
that are just sort of universal to chess
end games
um that always seem to ring true
regardless of the pieces on the board
even
so yeah you guys are exactly right you
know get rid of the night
the night's super annoying this bishop
while it
is you know on the same color as the
enemy pawns is having a pretty
difficult time uh actually coming up
with any concrete targets here
so the thing to do is simply play bishop
d3
uh and take off the knight uh in the
game uh kasparov plays the move g5
we see bishop takes on f5 bishop takes
on f5 and now knight e3
and quite clearly now it is a bad bishop
against a good night
and with this change uh comes a few
different things
and we'll talk about those in a moment
so bishop b1
played by anna or played by gary
kasparov
and now of course we go about the
business of making sure that these pawns
forever stay
on the light squares with the move b4 uh
really simple really nice move to play
you just make sure
that these pawns stay on the light
squares forever and also by the way
make sure you never really have to worry
about any you know king invasions on the
queen side
uh and now comes sort of the decision
of the game and unfortunately from a
lecturer's perspective
uh it sort of spoils the fun because
uh it's a it's a move that is sort of
really really difficult to come up with
in an actual chess game but when it's
presented as a puzzle it's a little bit
easier
to see the idea because the obvious
moves kind of get thrown
out so in the game kasparov plays g
takes h4
and then what do you people suppose what
do you people in the chat room
think anatoly karpov played in response
and why and why
what does karpov play here
so chess king is along the right track
knight f5 is along the right track but
unfortunately this
square is defended
king g2 is along the right track none of
these are
actually quite the the most accurate but
what everybody is realizing
is that the move is not g takes h4 so so
the question is essentially
why not take the pawn back you stupid
dummy
why not take the pawn back
and what nobody has found the move yet
uh and chess king finally does
chess king finally does so we would love
to play knight f5 we would love to play
it but it does hang at night
so instead we can settle for knight to
g2
and the reason for this move uh like it
if any move ever deserves a double x
clam it's knight g2 cause it just does
it all
right so what's the problem with g takes
h4 well first and foremost obviously
white is the one
trying to press for the win in the game
right black has this awful bishop
and all of our pawns are essentially
untargetable right there's just no way
that black can target any of our pawns
however
after g takes h4 there's one really
important factor
at play here and that is the fact that
black has
essentially built a great wall
um preventing our king from entering
uh into the position right like look at
that that's that's a wall right there
and if our king can't play we're not
gonna win the game
it's it's that simple if our king can't
get into the game
there's no way for us to make tangible
threats remember that principle right
the fewer pieces on the board the more
important king activity actually is
and so with g takes h4 the game is
simply dead there's no winning this
game pretty pretty much ever uh from any
perspective all black has to do
is guard this one square with the bishop
and you know make sure that
these three pawns don't hang like that
that is it it's not that
difficult of a task really i think
okay that's maybe too bold of a claim i
was gonna say i think
me maybe even i could draw this against
karpov given enough time
but that's not true i would find a way
uh anyways so why not a move like g4
well
g4 seems to to do a lot of the
a lot of the same things but perhaps it
is
uh trading off a bit too much and it
might not seem like it but
perhaps simply h takes g
um and if we play knight takes g for one
that this
is another reason why knight g2 rather
than king g2
is correct uh but if pawn g2 then um
simply something like like king to e6
perhaps and while we are
still coming this way uh i'm just not
convinced that it's going to be easy to
win with the g
pawn let us let us ask so yeah king g2
and actually
simply f5 is already an idea that we
have to contend with here and if we play
g5
then f4 and this is going to be uh going
to be a big problem
so this pawn is a little bit too far
advanced to play g4
and the problem with knight takes g4 is
the same problem with king g2
basically you're letting this king
activate itself
via the e6 square and we definitely
don't want that
so with king g2 again the problem
is you're not really gaining any time
and you're not activating your knight to
the maximum here the king can sort of
still participate whereas with knight g2
after h takes g3 check or h3 it doesn't
really matter uh if h3 still knight f4
is our plan
so hg3 instead takes uh now
king e6 but we have knight f4 check and
we have activated our knight
as well as our king so karpov with
knight g2 finds the best way to activate
all the pieces and very very importantly
still give this king a path to
participate in the game
now kasparov for his credit is
definitely not a pushover
i feel like a lot of players in this
position would try to do something awful
like bishop g6
and be like please don't hurt me please
don't hurt me please don't hurt me
but of course like you're gonna get hurt
you're gonna get hurt in this position
the king is too active for white
and after something like king e7 we can
simply take here
secure in the knowledge that our king
activity is going to win
going to win the game for example
pawn's dead um so
kasparov says all right fine you can
play knight f4 you
did just sacrifice a pawn though so i'm
going to come king f5
and activate my own king so
uh chat room wait to move in this
position do we take the h
pawn or do we take the d-pawn what do
you guys think
which pawn should be captured
which pawn should be captured
uh and arthur apparently had the answer
in the chat room congratulations arthur
now again the thing that's really
remarkable about knight g2
is not necessarily that uh karpov was
able to find it when he started thinking
but sort of that he was thinking that
hard at all about um
g takes h4neichi too like finding that
move unprovoked is
is pretty incredible in my opinion
all right and the chat room is split the
chat room is split nobody knows
nobody knows exquisite corpse has the
right answer
by saying d 100 because it'll be funnier
when he says we should take the h-pawn
and of course you should in fact take
the h-pawn
now why should you take the h-pawn how
does that make any sense at
all well it's kind of similar
kind of similar to why we didn't play g
takes h4
and the reason is we have a nice little
wall here
that keeps the black king from you know
being a big meanie and coming into the
queen side
and if we take this then believe it or
not this wall is actually
a little bit broken and we might live to
to regret uh giving this king this kind
of pathway
into the game for example let's play a
few moves bishop a2
knight c7 coming after this guy bishop
c4
knight a6 suddenly king e6 and while we
might still be coming in
this way black as well now has a pathway
into the game and uh again
just another really incredible decision
by karpov so of course
knight takes h5 with the idea of keeping
the king shut out of the game as well as
the bishop by the way as well as keeping
this bishop locked out
the d-pawn is essentially in black's way
so king e6 played by
kasparov kind of giving up on this
active king plan didn't really work out
if you go to a square like g5 now all of
a sudden
uh knight takes d5 is still a threat but
also importantly
knight e6 and knight knight to a6 is
coming as well for example with bishop
here
simply this and these are a lot of pawns
that you might not be so happy about
giving up
so king back to e6 for kasparov
now knight back to f4 check why not we
just snapped this pawn off the board may
as well come back
and this time kasparov says okay okay
okay okay okay
now that my h pawn's dead maybe i do
need to defend the g
pawn uh from here nothing too surprising
we have king
to g4 bishop c2 king to h5
our idea was to activate the king and so
karpov does it
and now bishop d1 and simply king to g6
again karpov doesn't even really care
about this f
pawn either what is important is
ensuring
that uh we get our king into the game
and we get
uh our activity so king to e7
is played in the game and now karpov
being you know not perhaps a super super
superhuman
doesn't actually play the best move here
so
chat room white to move what is the best
move
what is the best move here astoundingly
this is one of the most
incredible positions in chess
maybe i i like when i'm like i like
these classes because
i can just say things that don't have to
be true like this is one of the most
incredible positions in chess
maybe it is i don't know it's a matter
of opinion really
[Music]
and yeah almost has the the right the
right move so of course
knight takes d5 is what everybody uh
including karpov
and probably probably everybody would
play knight takes d5
clearly pawn is hanging with check
how are you not going to take it it
turns out
that the same logic that we used on this
turn
actually holds true on the the this
other decision point as well
it turns out the d-pawn is kind of in
black's way
it's kind of in black's way as far as
preventing uh
black from from getting any active
counterplay against the d-pawn
so incredibly here the correct move is
actually knight h5
um and i have done so much analysis in
this
end game i believe white is winning
after knight h5
i believe you can take on f6 and then
the game simply
um you know in white's hand now i'm not
gonna go down
this long and complicated analysis
because i don't want to
and i don't think you guys want to
either i think i
uh i think i've shown this position
before uh in lectures a long long time
ago
and i think we probably spent the whole
hour uh
just basically here um so what's the
point of knight h5 over knight d5
well once again the d5 pawn can
potentially just be
in black's way and with this extra pawn
here
white doesn't ever have to worry about a
king landing on d5
and believe it or not the king and the
knight are actually kind of able
to force the black king back and start
gaining some ground
with the white king into the position
and win the d-pawn at a more opportune
time
now that may sound difficult to believe
and perhaps it is
but um uh from what i can tell at least
it's
it's true uh from a lot of analysis with
computers
so not getting into all that though
knight takes d5
is perhaps the more human move and it's
what was played in the game we see king
e6
by black knight c7 check
king d7 and actually by the way
king d7 is perhaps a bit of a mistake
king d6 is better
for the obvious reason that it is closer
to the d5 square
so king d7 instead now knight takes a6
bishop takes f3 and king takes f6
and now the evaluation of this position
i think is also probably winning for
white at this point
but notably we follow down the same path
with king to d6
instead now knight takes on a6
bishop takes on f3 king takes on f6
the immediate king to d5 uh i i think is
simply drawing the game
um so of course the players could have
gone down a different path
but the absence of this d5 pawn does
make it so that black can get this sort
of active play
and i i believe draw the game as for
this position
the white king is simply a little bit
too far away to
to be able to help these pawns advance
forward
uh for example now the bishop is just
going to sacrifice
and that will be that so absolutely
crazy stuff i
don't really know why uh kasparov chose
kd7
maybe kasparov was worried about the
line after knight to e8
but honestly um king to d5 would
actually be a mistake here i should
mention
due to knight takes f6 when the f pawn
is actually good enough to win
but the crazy move king back to e7 is
actually good enough
for kasparov in this case after knight
takes bishop takes here and we actually
have very good control over this knight
and white's going to have a difficult
time finding a path
into the into the position for example
king f5 king d6
and white will always always always have
to worry about this king d5 threat
and that's going to make it really tough
to win so
instead king d7 played in the game and
this is now
a tough position for black and probably
lost we get king d6
king f5 king d5 king f4 gaining a key
tempo on the bishop
bishop h1 and now king e3 just in time
to maintain a two pawn advantage and go
on to win the game
we get king c4 now knight c5
uh bishop c6 is a really important move
here
white is perhaps threatening to do
something like knight e4
and cut this bishop out of the game
along with knight d6 threats
so bishop c6 makes that not so dangerous
but now knight d3
uh is played as well once again
king to b3 is simply going to be a
little bit too slow i believe
for example uh knight to e5 bishop d5
king d3 king a3 king c3 and the king is
basically entombed you have to go this
way
and that would be tough okay
so instead we get bishop c6 uh knight d3
bishop back to g2 which is passing the
time
we get the check on e5 now king c3 and
uh now knight g6 is a nice move to aim
for f4 controlling the d5 square
and advancing the pawn also by the way
aiming for the e7 square perhaps even
more relevantly
now we do see king back to c4 again the
problem with king b3 is that you sort of
get entombed
after uh king d3 king a3 and king c3
when of course white is still easily
winning so bishop
or king c4 instead 97 now and
it's just a matter of time at this point
we end up with this check
and this pawn falling as well and the
rest is history here as kasparov
chose this moment to throw in the towel
so uh
that last part of the game still some
some definite complications there as far
as karpov walking
walking the line between uh defending
his own pawns
and shuffling around with the knight to
advance his pawn but really
the the key moments of the game there
being those moments where
uh karpov uh the first time chose
to not capture back on h4 then later
chose to take on h5 rather than d5
giving himself a passed pawn
and then later giving kasparov that
chance back into the game
by playing knight takes d5 rather than
the astounding move
knight h5 so really uh incredible end
game here
by by karpov and kasparov alike really
fun stuff to
see so questions on this one before we
call it a night here and head on
over to the twitch channel questions for
me
does he read the chat i do read the chat
here i am i'm reading
however it's difficult for me to
multitask so reading and talking at the
same time
not so easy
all right well not too many questions i
guess
um so yeah thank you all so much for
watching as i said
this will unfortunately be i think my
last
uh edition of the end game class i've
had a lot of fun
you know honestly this class is such a
boring name
but it gets uh almost almost the most
viewers
of any of the classes i do so apparently
there's a hunger for endgames
uh dorsa derek shawnee is actually going
to be taking over the class
uh whether or not she sticks with
endgames is going to be up to her i
think she probably will for the first
week but no guarantees there
so stay tuned for the wednesday classes
they will all still be at the same time
but dorsa is taking the helm rather than
myself
if you do want more of me in particular
please tune in on tuesday nights from
here on out at 6 30
central time i will be teaching the road
to 2000
and uh all of this will be uh
as what will be the same moving forward
if you want all of the details by the
way please check out our website
stuffclub.org
for further details alright guys well
thank you all so much for watching as
always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next tuesday goodbye